so
i'm dying to know
like
from
all the network tv money you know like
that that's your family matters went on
for how many seasons man it was like
612. we did 215 episodes we did nine
seasons and we went off the air in 1998.
so we got some serious anniversaries
coming up man yeah right oh yeah um
because when back then the network tv
money was was meaningful oh stupid you
know and so you got that piling up yeah
we were just talking to frankie muniz
yep and uh he was really smart with his
money oh yeah frankie
he's [ __ ] buying park parking lots
and [ __ ]
so uh
i mean it's it's it's a [ __ ]
question and don't and then feel free to
feel free to tell me so yeah but did you
did you stack that money up properly and
did you take care of it but my dad was
really into stocks so i was really i was
really lucky in that way and we were
also able to do some really cool things
in real estate um in uh the san diego
area and uh
in the vegas area um i also owned a few
homes in the palisades for a while um so
i was able to always keep flipping
things like that through my parents
believe it or not
but more importantly i'm a part owner in
the show so wow that was that was the
rarity for family matters with me is
that they did make me a part owner in
the show were you the only part owner or
a lot more people part owner part
no
whoa he just looked at me like you know
so it's like sometimes you know you you
got a raw deal in certain areas and um i
do look back on it and i know that that
if uh
diversity issues back then had been
different um yes
it could have been an even sweeter deal
but i will always be grateful for the
partial ownership that i do have in the
show
it has definitely uh so so it's uh gone
on and like with syndication like uh and
we never could and the thing was we
never could have known that it would pay
it would pay out the way it did
because
if you think about it there were a
million popular shows back then though
dog give me everything from drew carey
to you
exactly you don't know
10 20 30 years from now what's going to
emerge as the brady bunch type show
right that just goes on forever so
scooby-doo just generation or whatever
and that's like that i'm more like
scooby-doo than i am you know it's crazy
that you know the cosby show will never
air again probably right and family
matters is still running you couldn't
have told me right that was what what
you know that's that was going to be so
i always like to feel for people like oh
this person's really smart with their
money and this daniel was like look man
god has us all on individual journeys
and you know you just got to get lucky
sometimes yeah i dig that you know what
i'm saying and you got to know you know
i've had times where i've had it good
i've had times really good i've had
times where it was like okay i'm just
kind of making a doctor's living this
year um but um but yeah that part
ownership has been a really a real
saving grace and did you own the
character too like lunch boxes and [ __ ]
because urkel was on everything yeah so
it's like it's really weird when it
comes to the ownership of the character
because it's like
no talent deal was ever um extracted
from the original property
and then i i unfortunately a lot of my
um my e-commerce is bootleg and so you
know warner brothers never defended that
so that was really one of the one of the
things also that really
really inspired me to
um to build its purple because i just
wanted some images out there that were
owned by me and protected by me
yeah i mean it's clear that you're being
careful about copyright by just calling
it it's purple yeah well that well no
actually it's purple everything i do is
about a story
so it's purple really it's about um a
wanting to be the best in the purple
spectrum okay you know on for for all
purples but also when people would see
me in the streets they would be like on
the low they'd be like hey dude it's
circle and they do that crap like as if
i can't see them they're very
transparent to me and so i always just
wanted something cool to say back one
day and so it's like no it's purple
and it's like that's that that's that
was like the hook the story of something
i've lived my entire life of people
recognizing me not so discreetly but
thinking so sure uh but purple article
the strain is just public domain
anybody's any if they make it like a cab
or like i said the wine industry anybody
can you can make whatever cab you want
but you still got to brand it yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's
selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]